the spider-man far from home official
trailer was meant to drop last week but
unfortunately due to the Avengers
endgame trailer being pushed back far
from home is now reportedly supposed to
drop on the 18th of December however
after a Sony panel at Brazil's comic-con
visitors were treated to its debut and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the events that happen in it there
will be heavy spoilers here and so if
you don't want to know anything then I
highly suggest that you turn off now for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so the trailer opens with
Peter Parker and May and happy Hogan
discussing Pierce school trip after the
events of Avengers endgame Pierre is
determined to take a break from
superheroing and whilst packing he
leaves his spider-man costume at home
the class then arrived at Venice and
dropped by several landmarks and it
appears that there's a romance brewing
between Peter and Michelle Ned MPA
relaxed in a room before Ned is shot
with the tranquilizer which puts him to
sleep Nick Fury steps forward and says
that he has a mission for Pierre and
presents him the stealth suit that we've
seen in many leaked images the trailer
ends with Mysterio teaming up with
spider-man to take down Hydra man
there's a big action scene and it
becomes clear that Mysterio is working
alongside Nick Fury or perhaps even for
him Mysterio doesn't have his fishbowl
helmet though but I can imagine that
this gets added in later in the movie
okay so the trailer is incredibly short
but it also has a fun vibe to it that I
think works really well with the
character obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it below so make sure
you leave a comment giving your opinion
on the leaked footage if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of into the spider
version as well as its post-credit scene
which would be linked at the end of this
video this is a channel for people who
were super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]